recently a CES we saw the implementation
of HDMI 2.1 in new 4k and 8k TV's HDMI
2.1 brings up to 120 Hertz at 4k and up
to 60 Hertz at 8k and even 10k
resolutions but house HDMI 2.1 different
from HDMI 2.0 and is it worth it
[Music]
welcome to hurry saw is HDMI 2 point 1
is much faster than HDMI 2.0 which is
pretty much mainstream and awful
mentioning many devices right now
it almost triples the bandwidth of HDMI
2.0 with the maximum speed of up to 48
gigabits per second as opposed to eat
teeny bits per second with HDMI 2.0 for
4k TVs that means that HDMI 2.1 offers
120 Hertz at 4k as opposed to 60 Hertz
at 4k with HDMI 2 or no for 8k HDMI 2.0
1 brings in 60 Hertz as opposed to 24 to
30 Hertz with hdmi 2.0 also something to
keep in mind is that this is the
natively transmitted video and not
motion processed often times scaling and
motion processing can actually make the
image look much inferior but with this
look at much smaller action which is
much less artificial furthermore hdmi
2.1 even supports 10k resolution but
with how new 8k tvs are is going to be a
very long time before 10k tvs at the
market on top of that you get d HDR or
dynamic high dynamic range yes that's a
pretty weird name but anyways d HDR
makes the dynamic range variable instead
of static which is what is found in a
chart displays right now this results in
better shadows in the dark and more
highlights in bright scenarios if you
are interested in what HDR is and how it
works
they make sure to check out my dedicated
video on it right there the vr r stands
for variable refresh rate which
will lead to much less image like
stutter and caring this is very similar
to what G sync and gsync achieved on the
PC platform this is great news for
gamers because HDMI 2.1 will allow
graphics processors to render and show
images in real time this will lead to
much more fluid gameplay in more detail
finally hdmi 2.0 on brings VAR z or
audio return channel which loves a
display to send back audio to a device
for example if you're watching netflix
on your TV but you want the sound to
come out to a sound bar this is what a
lot for that happened e AR c or enhanced
audio return channel it's just a simple
update that increases the bandwidth
which will allow for more standards of
audio to be supported so in the end hdmi
2.1 introduces better support for higher
resolution displays introduces d HDR
which will provide better colors brings
game mode via our art and updates AR c
so should go out and buy one well the
big issue is that you need to have a
display and the source that both support
hdmi 2.1 there is no firmware update
that you can do to make it supported you
have to have buy a TV and source that
was supported natively and 8k TVs aren't
even closed like at all it's still going
to take several years for them to even
become flagships and several more years
for them to become a commonplace so
unless you're thinking about buying a
new 8k 120 first refresh rate monitor
with a video card that supports HDMI 2.1
then just hdmi 2.1 cable is actually
pretty useless for you also if you're
considering upgrading everything from
your TV to your blu-ray player to your
audio system just because it is outdated
than ah and you're having trouble
deciding whether or not to go with the
2.1 standard then if your says
significant amount of mighty can say by
not going with it and i strongly
recommend that pad
4k 60 hertz tvs are significantly
cheaper and so really really good
displays also only selective content
we'll even be available for that viewing
style and yes you can upscale but I
really just don't think that it is worth
it so just take it easy and get a great
TV without prioritizing hdmi 2.1 if you
can get it for not that much more then
yeah go for it
but if you have to splurge a lot more
money than in-plane 19 it's definitely
not worth it
but that's just what i think what do you
guys think what are your thoughts and 8k
TVs when do you think you'll become
mainstream and are you going to be
getting one in the imminent future make
sure comment that down below also if you
guys like this video and always help for
the measure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you'd like to see more
videos just like this one but no then
I'm hurried and I'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]